ABOUT IT.
THEY'RE NOT HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT REAL
SOLUTIONS.
>> REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK JOINS US
NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, WE SEE THIS
STRATEGY HERE.
HILLARY USED IT YESTERDAY AND
SHE AS USING IT NOW, THAT CRIME
AND THE THREATS OF CRIME IS A
TACTIC BEING USED BY OTHERS IT'
PERCEPTION PROBLEM MORE THAN A
REALITY PROBLEM FOR IT.
>> HERE'S THE BEST PART OF THE
CLIPPARD SHE SAYING THAT RIGHT
NEXT TO THEY ARE SHOWING ALL TH
DIFFERENT MAJOR CRIME CATEGORIE
THAT ARE UP YEAR-OVER-YEAR.
SHE SAYS IT'S DATA DENIAL TO SA
THAT WE HAVE A CRIME ISSUE, SHE
SAYS IT'S A CONSPIRACY.
EVEN CNN THIS MORNING WHEN SHE
IS DOING SIDE-BY-SIDE, IT
SHOWING MAJOR CRIME CATEGORY ON
AFTER ANOTHER.
THIS MORNING I'M AT PURE 45
WHERE THERE WAS THAT TERRIBLE
ATTACK THEY JUST REFERENCED AND
IN NEW YORK CITY RATE IS UP
YEAR-OVER-YEAR.
WHAT PEOPLE WANT FOR THEIR
CANDIDATES WHETHER IT'S THE
GOVERNOR TO BE TALKING ABOUT HO
WE UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE UPSET
ABOUT THIS, HERE ARE MY
SOLUTIONS FOR FIXING IT.
WE SUPPORT THE MEN AND WOMEN
WANT ENFORCEMENT, WE'RE GOING T
FIRE THAT REFUSED TO IMPACT THE
LAW.
DO NOT GETTING THAT LEADERSHIP
THEY JUST WANT THE DEFLECTION
AND THE DISTRACTION TO TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
THEY WANT US FOCUSED ON ISSUES
LIKE CRIME AND THE ECONOMY THEY
DON'T WANT US TO COME UP WITH
SOME EXCUSE FOR WHY THERE'S NO
RESPONSIBILITY WITH IS.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH
IT, DON'T RUN FOR THE POSITION
FRED.
>> WE HAVE A QUESTION FROM
GABRIEL AND NY USE STUDENT.
>> GOOD EVENING, CONGRESSMAN
ZELDIN.
I AM A FIRST-YEAR COLLEGE
STUDENT NEW YORK CITY.
IN RECENT YEARS I'VE SEEN THE
CITY THAT I LOVE DETERIORATE AN
BECOME A SHELL OF ITSELF BECAUS
OUR ELECTED LEADERS DO NOT WANT
TO ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT KEEP U
SAFE.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO AS GOVERNOR T
ADDRESS MY CONCERNS ABOUT PUBLI
SAFETY?
>> THE FIRST THING I WOULD DUKE
OF THE FIRST DAY I'M IN OFFICE
IS TELL THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
HE'S BEING REMOVED FOR HIS
REFUSAL TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WELL PLAN A IS FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO COME TO THE TABL
AND WORK WITH ME, THEY SAY
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE NEED TO
ROLLBACK THESE PROGRAM AND
ALLOWS LIKE CASHLESS BAIL, SO
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO UNTO YOU
ONE D1 IS WE ARE GOING TO
DECLARE A CRIME EMERGENCY HERE
IN THE STATE OF NEW YORK AND WE
ARE GOING TO SUSPEND CASHLESS
BAIL, LESS IS MORE, THE
DISCOVERY LAW CHANGES, WE HAVE
TO FORCE THEM TO COME TO THE
TABLE.
YOU DESERVE YOUR GOVERNOR TO BE
DOING ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER TO MAKE YOUR LIFE
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY SAFER ON
THE STREETS IN IN THE SUBWAYS.
I'M ALSO RELIEVED TO THINK ABOU
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
WHO'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
SLEEP ON JANUARY 1ST KNOWING
THAT ONCE AGAIN THEY HAVE A
GOVERNOR WHO HAS THEIR BACK.
>> CONGRESSMAN, PEOPLE HAVE
HEARD ME SAY SO MANY TIMES THAT
REAGAN CAMPAIGNED IN THE BRONX
IN 1980 HE ENDED HIS CAMPAIGN I
THE BRONX AND MADE SEVERAL STOP
IN YORK.
HE TOOK THE CAMPAIGN TO ALL 50
STATES.
HE WENT TO THE BELLY OF THE
BEAST OF LIBERALISM, YOU DID
THAT TODAY, WHICH I LOVE IN
GREENWICH VILLAGE.
I LOVE GREENWICH VILLAGE, BUT
IT'S REALLY LEFT-WING.
YOU WERE MET WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF PROTEST.
WATCH.
>> GO BACK TO LONG ISLAND.
>> GET OUT OF HERE.
>> OKAY, SO THAT WAS LIKE FOR
PEOPLE, BUT GO BACK TO LONG
ISLAND.
THIS IS A THAT IF YOU'RE NOT
DIED IN THE WOOL DEMOCRAT YOU
ARE NOT A REAL NEW YORKER.
MEMBER KATHY SAID THAT NOT VERY
LONG.
>> SHE IS NO LONGER OWN NEW
YORKER.
T DEMANDED THAT I GET ON A BUS
AND MOVED TO FLORIDA IF YOU WAN
TO BE THE GOVERNOR COMING HAVE
TO BE WILLING AND WANT TO BE TH
GOVERNOR FOR ALL NEW YORKERS,
BUT SHE'S NOT WILLING TO DO THAT
.
>> SO WHY DID YOU GO?
WHY WAS IT IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
GO TO GREENWICH VILLAGE?
>> THE PEOPLE THEY ARE WANT TO
SEE THEIR LEADERS SHOWING UP.
YESTERDAY A WOMAN IS JOGGING AN
SHE GETS CHOKED AND ASSAULTED.
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THAT
COMMUNITY ARE SHOCKED BY WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE ALL SHOULD BE THERE.
WE SHOULD ALL BE THERE TALKING
ABOUT OUR IDEAS TO MAKE SURE
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
WITH THAT LAST QUESTION I
MENTION ON DAY ONE I WILL DO A
CRIME EMERGENCY.
THOSE PEOPLE SHOUTING TAKE ONE
OF THEM SHOUTS OUT THERE IS NO
CRIME EMERGENCY.
ACTUALLY THERE IS AN PEOPLE WAN
TO SEE THAT LEADERSHIP FROM US
AND THEY'RE NOT GETTING IT FROM
KATHY HOCHUL.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING IT WHEN
THEY SHOW UP FOR A RALLY.
THERE IS A REASON WHY AT THE
SAME TIME WE HAD ABOUT 3,000
PEOPLE IN THE CAPITAL.
WE HAVE THE MOMENTUM AND WE HAV
THE ENERGY.
>> Laura: IN GETTING READ OF
ALL THE VACCINE MANDATES.
>> ENDING THE COVID VACCINE
MANDATES.
>> HEALTHCARE WORKERS, POLICE,
ALL GONE PURKEY EVERY SINGLE
PERSON WHO WAS FIRED.
>> THEIR JOBS BA